this goes to your point where
you you talked about China India and
Africa and he added Latin America they
are concerned of poverty that's their
main concern so we have the luxury here
in the United States or in the EU to
things are so good we forget how good we
have it here that we'll move on to
other issues that are so magnified
beyond our daily living that we all
right we're going to Saint Greta of
climate change right whereas people
struggling to put food on the table in
poorer countries or countries that have
famines or countries where wealth
inequality is completely exacerbated
their day-to-day living concerns are not
the global climate and that's kind of
what you were saying initially right
yeah